22:14 minute 58
you can see like most games bunch of
fans have left which is always great not
a lot of traffic alright a minute 24
left
2114 balls on the 42 yard line of team
rice
they always get it down to there they go
for the two-point conversion I'm the
only person in the state that still
gives a
let's go carry
minute 5 left 30 yard gain look at that
after one play come on Alice the fact
that in the clock and the clock stop
compressions my second and 10 57 seconds
left
Alex Smith looking confident they track
the pass
who says grow balls on exciting who says
that on your mother
alright 51 second second 51 seconds left
I'm drunk
there's only 20 yards between them
I'm getting all the two boys are we
gonna have an oversight most exciting
promo 98% economist Jerry Rice see Jerry
right they're going for
that field goal kicker on the bench
21 20 funniest sees plenty of seats hold
up a plastic chairs
all right with the huddle we all know
what we're going to do
hilarious
okay
there was some cigars won and lost on
that break
yeah they kind of skipped the kickoff
goes six seconds left I don't know what
just happened
Rosie price just went up by two I'm air
one on a two-point conversion they
skipped the kickoff 26 seconds 25 bucks
ticking down up guessing team Sanders is
out of timeouts I'm guessing there's 30
people in the continental United States
watching the crowds going crazy over the
middle trinsic seconds
on a timeout left
that's got to be the last time out
there's no way this isn't the most
exciting Pro Bowl
foods on the alcohol that I could see
by
all right here it is the final play of
the game nine seconds nine seconds ago
22:21 team rice games and is glad enough
confident there in the scrub off it's
there
ah
the quarterback position during that
for some reason the clock starts
who's the Eagles quarterback again Jay
fielder falls annuals